I would like to introduce my colleague
carolyn levy to my right here who's
going to talk about startup mechanics
and then with john levy and jason quan
they'll answer some questions about
getting your startup started legal
issues i will point out that these three
folks are probably the finest legal
minds in the startup world these and i
and i do not exaggerate they may hate me
saying it but these folks have seen more
they've worked with more startups in
more situations than you could believe
and some of the situations you wouldn't
believe so they know everything and so i
do hope you listen carefully and I do
hope look I know we gave you Eve
everyone homework to watch videos from
from 2014 in 2017 on startup mechanics I
urge you all to watch those videos if
you haven't already as as an adjunct to
what Carolyn and and John and Jason are
about to say because you will find them
useful as you build your company so
Carolyn thank you Jeff totally
exaggerated but we have seen a lot of
stuff okay so like Jeff just mentioned
back in 2014 Kirstie and I did a
start-up school lecture on legal and
accounting mechanics and we were hoping
that most of you would have time to
watch that before you came here today
I'm going to blaze through a recap of
that and just touch on the key takeaways
from not lecture but I am gonna skip the
part about investors and fundraising
because Kirstie is actually gonna do an
entirely separate lecture on that stuff
later on in the program next I'm going
to go through some common mistakes and
problems that we see founders make and
finally Jason and John are gonna come up
here and I want to thank all of you who
sent in email questions to us beforehand
because we're gonna go through some of
those on the some of
legal mechanics questions that you guys
already submitted okay
so um the first thing you have to do
when you're starting a start-up is
actually form your separate legal entity
this is your company and the act of
incorporating is just filing a document
called a certificate of incorporation
which is really short and simple for
startups and you go and you file it with
the Department of corporations in
whatever state you choose to incorporate
in now we strongly recommend choosing
Delaware because the process in that
state is really really easy and the
service is really fast and efficient and
that's the primary reason we suggest but
also as a lot of you probably know you
know most public companies are Delaware
companies so that saves you a little
time if your gonna go public and some
investors actually will require that
you're in Delaware before they before
they'll fund you so that's another good
reason to ban Delaware okay so this has
been mentioned a couple times already
we also strongly recommend that you use
an online platform specifically geared
to startups to incorporate and there's a
lot of these platforms some are good
some are not so good Clerke and stripe
outlets have already been mentioned and
those are the two that we think are
great they're YC companies we have
extensive experience with Clerke and I
was really happy to hear that Darby Wong
one of the founders of Clerke is gonna
do an AMA because he's great one of the
reasons why we think clerking stripe
outlets are so great is because they
don't stop after formation they also
have post incorporation documents and
some of the not so good platforms stop
after formation and they don't do post
incorporation and one of the things that
doesn't happen if you don't do post
incorporation is founders don't buy
their stock and when we were commuting
down here today Jason reminded me of a
story a really big company and a really
big law firm and they didn't the
founders never bought their stock and
this wasn't discovered until the Series
B financing so if you think this sounds
weird like of course the founders need
to buy stock look this is a mistake that
ax
happens okay another step in the
incorporation process is forming a Board
of Directors and for early startups the
members of the board are usually the
founders if you're a solo founder you
can have a board of one if you are two
founders you can have a board of two um
there's a misconception that board of
directors have to have an odd number of
Directors but that is not necessary and
then you need to appoint corporate
officers you need to have a president
and/or a CEO you can't have both if you
want and in Delaware you're required to
have a corporate secretary and another
part of the process is adopting
corporate bylaws for start-ups bylaws
can be extremely generic and finally
this isn't technically part of the
incorporation process but I encourage
you to open a corporate bank account as
soon as possible
most startups won't have very much cash
to put in that bank account but it's
great to get into the habit of treating
the corporation as a separate entity as
early as possible and I it's critical to
form good habits around the way you
treat your company's money okay so post
incorporation so now we're gonna go back
to what I just said about issuing
founders stock you all know that
corporations are owned by stockholders
and you and your co-founders are going
to be the first stockholders okay if you
are a founder team of two or more you
have to think about how you're going to
allocate that stock our belief about the
best way to allocate stock among
founders is to think about the challenge
of execution and that's another way of
saying the following do not place too
much importance on the founder that had
the idea for the business because all of
the hard work is in front of the team
and all of the value is going to be
created in the future if you are all
going to be working hard going forward
but you all are we think the equity
split should be more or less equal among
you if you and your co-founders are
having a really hard time coming to a
consensus about stock allocation there
may be underlying trust or commitment
issues with the team so you want to pay
close
attention to that okay founders need to
purchase their shares from the company
and you buy them using a stock purchase
agreement you actually have to pay for
them but fortunately the stock of a
brand-new company is very cheap the way
most founders stock purchase agreements
work is that you give a very very small
amount of cash and then you contribute
to the company any intellectual property
that you've created so that's the total
purchase price for your founder shares
founders shares should be subject to
vesting and this bet ties back to the
point I just made about all the work
being ahead of you vesting means that
you don't get full ownership of your
stock until a certain period of time has
passed during the voting during the
vesting period whether you can vote all
of your shares but if you quit your
company before the full period of time
has passed
the company will automatic automatically
repurchase all of your unvested shares
when shares are subject to vesting
they're called restricted stock so your
founder stock purchase agreement will be
actually a restricted stock purchase
agreement and as I'm sure most of you
know the standard or typical vesting
period is about four years so I'm not
gonna get into cap tables in this
lecture because Kirsty
is going to explain them in detail in
her lecture about fundraising mechanics
but the basic idea is that every company
absolutely needs to keep a cap table you
need to keep a record of every single
share of stock that your company issues
and we used to have to do these on these
complicated Excel spreadsheets but
fortunately there are now multiple
online platforms that will keep track of
stock ownership you know effortlessly
and we'll make sure that those resources
are included on you know on one of these
on on the forum okay because founders
tend to identify so closely with their
startup it's easy to forget that they
actually need to be employees of their
company we're look at that so it's
pretty self-evident that most founders
can't pay themselves in the early days
of their startup because practically if
there's no money you can't have payroll
but if there is enough money
it's a really good idea for founder's to
pay themselves minimum wage strictly
speaking it's against the law not to pay
yourselves although obviously this isn't
a thing that that gets enforced okay um
so employment whether a founders or
others does not require an employment
agreement employment agreements are
actually are not actually appropriate
for startups because employment is at
will by default and the basics of hiring
and firing are governed by law anyway
in fact employment agreements can
sometimes complicate things because
courts may interpret certain of the
language an employment agreement as
changing that default at-will status to
a for-cause status which makes it a lot
harder to terminate people so an
employee agreement is only necessary if
you're hiring employee who's going to
have something special like a severance
package and we really don't see those in
startups but what is really really
important is that all the founders and
in the future you know everyone who
works for your company has signed a C
III a or a PII a and I'm sure a lot of
you heard of these it's a confidential
or proprietary information invention
assignment agreement agreement the CI ia
protects the company's confidential
information and trade secrets and
ensures that all the intellectual
property that is because created is
owned by the company so you want
everyone in the company signed up to one
of these very early-stage startups
usually cannot afford to have employees
but the solution is not to convince
people to work for your company for free
it's one thing for founders to work for
free but it's significantly riskier for
non founders creating work product and
other intellectual property to work for
no compensation
so unfortunately all of you all have to
do all the work until you can afford to
hire up so I'm gonna wrap up this
summary and digress from legal mechanics
for to make a few common sense points
and my belief my personal belief is that
ignoring these points can cause you to
waste a lot of time fixing problems
later these are really common mistakes
so ideally you will have opened a
corporate bank account as part of or
right after incorporating the company
hopefully you have a little bit of money
in it so you should use that for all of
your company expenses if the company
bank account has no money in it and you
are paying for all the business expenses
with your own personal savings the
company can reimburse you later when it
eventually has money but you absolutely
need to keep all the receipts and you
need to document everything carefully
corporations have to pay taxes if your
startup is a Delaware corporation there
is an annual tax you have to pay to that
state but if you calculate it correctly
the tax owed is really minor for
startups corporations also have to pay
Corp they also have to file a corporate
tax return with the IRS
obviously when your company's just
getting started you're not going to
actually owe they are as any taxes but
you still have to file the return and if
your startup does have employees even if
it's just the founders getting minimum
wage you need to pay payroll taxes and
the best way to do this is to get set up
with an online payroll service of which
there are many oh this is a personal
favorite of mine so you need to find a
good place to store the company's legal
documents like the certificate of
incorporation the bylaws the CI IAS the
founder stock restrictions agreements
founders stock purchase agreements for
example a shared Dropbox folder is a
good idea do not store them in a
co-founders email because you do not
want one person to control the access to
these very important documents also make
sure that the legal documents that you
are carefully collecting and storing are
actually the signed and dated versions
and triple check to make sure that there
are every blank is signed by every party
that needs to sign it later when your
company is fundraising and investors are
doing due diligence on your company it
just looks really amateur when you serve
up a bunch of formation documents and
there's a bunch of blanks in them all
right so that's the summary of that oh
sorry one more thing I just wanted to
mention what is acting like a real
company and my opinion is that
acting if you treat your startup like a
board of directors governed taxpaying
founder employee confidential
information holding entity that that's
the way to act like a real company and
this is also the only way you're going
to get protection from personal
liability which is the whole point of
supporting a separate legal entity
anyway okay
now we're going to move on to common
mistakes and problems okay I don't know
when to form a corporation so this isn't
actually a problem or a mistake I just
wanted to talk about it here and it
turns out that a lot of you emailed us
this question so the right timing on
when to pull the trigger on
incorporating is going to actually be
different for every startup but in
general we believe in doing it sooner
rather than later and so my top four
reasons about why you want to do this
would be number one because forming a
corporation protects you and your
co-founders from personal liability for
your company's actions number two the
Corp you know the corporation is the
correct repository for all of the
intellectual property that you and your
co-founders are creating otherwise
you're all just working on a project the
separate pieces of which are owned by
individuals and to me that's a hackathon
not a corporation number three you can't
raise you all know this you can't raise
real money for your startup without
forming corporation first because your
mom might give you some money for your
startup but no professional investor is
going to wire money to your personal
bank account
and you need to have a corporation in
order to have payroll and you can't
enter into contracts or with you know
vendors or consultants or potential
customers but personally and if you try
to do these things that is individual
it's super messy I formed an LLC instead
of a corporation because I got advice
that LLC's are better for taxes so for
our purposes this is usually a mistake
because even though LLC's are better for
optimizing taxes the vast majority of
angels and VC firms will not invest in
an LLC so
if you plan to fundraise from people
other than a small group of your friends
and family your startup needs to be a
corporation the question that several of
you asked in the emails is whether there
are other reasons besides fundraising
considerations to form a corporation
instead of an LLC and so in other words
if you're not planning to fundraise for
a long time after starting your company
does it make sense to start out as an
LLC and then switch to a corporation
later and in my opinion my opinion the
answer is no because I don't believe the
tax benefits of an LLC are compelling
enough to outweigh the inconvenience of
converting your LLC into a corporation
later and for those of you who watched
the 2014 startup school lecture kirstine
I told an anecdote about a company that
was an LLC and they had to convert into
a Delaware corporal nightmare it's
obviously an outlier but we do see this
a lot at YC we see a lot of LLC to
corporate conversions and it's um it's
just kind of a headache
you don't need okay I'm thinking about
hiring a lawyer to incorporate my
company so this is usually not a mistake
if your startup is really complicated
for some reason or if you've already
formed a non-us entity and you now want
to come to United States and raise money
in these cases you probably do need to
get a lawyer but I'm sure all of you
know lawyers are very expensive so save
money and use one of the good online
platforms that we just talked about firm
corporation also realize that lawyers
who are free like family members doing
you a favor may not be actually as good
as the online platforms because they
don't specialize in corporate
transactional work so your Aunt Sally
who does personal injury may mean well
but Clerke and stripe outlets will do a
much better job I'm starting to startup
but I still have a full-time job this is
actually already come up today a common
problem for founders because it's a big
decision to ditch the security of a
salary I think some of the other
speakers in this course will talk about
sort of the psychology of taking that
plunge but if you've decided to work on
your startup in
your spare time the primary legal
consideration is just keeping everything
separate so in California for example if
you're working on your startup on your
own time with your own resource
resources your current employer should
have no claim on your new business idea
so use a different computer don't work
on it during business hours but keep in
mind that different states and even
different countries have very different
rules about this particular issue and
there's things like non-compete
non-compete agreements with your
employer that may come into play so if
you're gonna do this you really should
do a little bit of research first or get
legal help our founding team has been
working on this idea for years so we
don't need vesting on our founder shares
this is a broken record we hear this all
the time this is a big mistake if you
don't have vesting you are setting your
company up for future problems no
investor wants to put money into a
company with founders who may decide the
next day that their burned out so they
take their shares and they leave but the
more common scenario is that one member
of a family founding team decides that
he or she is burned out and so leaves
the company with a giant ownership stake
the remaining founders have to do all
the work but someone who's not doing any
work has the same ownership it is
painful to fix this problem because the
price of the company's stock may have
increased in the interim and it becomes
really expensive for the remaining
founders to allocate the share ownership
fairly how many of you how many of you
are single founders I'm just curious
quite a few okay okay so I'm a single
founder and I don't need vesting you may
be thinking I think this is also a
mistake single founders obviously don't
have the same problems that founder
teams do but no vesting is still
unattractive to investors for the same
reasons also you will eventually hire
employees and probably grant them stock
options and those stock options will
have vesting and it just is a lot better
when you lead by example all right
another personal favorite I signed a
legal document but I was too busy to
read it so I have no idea what it is
this happens a lot if this is a big
mistake we see founders do this all the
time and I mean we sympathize right the
legal mechanics of your startup are the
really boring parts of the process you
can get away with not reading every word
of your bylaws for example but you need
to understand every provision in your
founder stock purchase agreement you
actually don't want to have anything
happen with your company's stock that
you don't know every word of and this is
actually a bigger problem it's not this
isn't such a huge problem with formation
documents it's a big problem with
fundraising documents I can't tell you
how many founders have told me they
won't read a five-page safe so you want
to get into the habit now of reading all
of your company documents it's daunting
it's legalese whatever read it anyway
understand it it's a great habit to get
into and then you'll know if it isn't
signed okay my friend offered to work
for my startup for free so I'm going to
pay her with shares generally this is a
mistake because people who work for your
company need to be paid money obviously
compensation packages can include an
equity component but paying with only
stock is not a good idea the exception
is if your friend can be hired by your
company as a consultant or independent
contractor those are the same thing and
it's okay for consultants to be paid for
services with just stock but you have to
first get comfortable that your friend
is properly classified as an independent
contractor and the rules in California
about this just changed and got stricter
also you'll want to make sure you paper
this relationship with a good consulting
agreement because you really want to
make sure that the company owns all of
the consultants work product you don't
want to wing it
okay this is a big one my co-founder and
I don't want to work together anymore
so this is sometimes a small problem and
this is sometimes a fatal problem
startups die sometimes because of this
and it happens unfortunately a lot and
it can be overwhelming
the acrimonious it's kind of like
watching people get a divorce
so the reason to pay careful attention
to the points I've already mentioned
like paying yourselves having vesting on
your founders shares having a CII a that
clearly demonstrates that the company
owns all the IP that's created doing
these things can significantly decrease
the legal drama around breakups I don't
know what decreases the emotional drama
but that decreases the legal drama my
company has some employees and I promise
to issue them stock this isn't a problem
as long as you take action on it sooner
rather than later and the appropriate
action to take is to adopt a stock
incentive plan and to grant stock to
these early employees a stock plan as
some of you probably know is like a 15
to 20 page document it references a
specific number of shares of your
company's common stock that are
allocated to the plan the company can
issue restricted stock or stock options
pursuant to the plan but what you need
to know about stock options is that if
you grant stock options you have to get
something called a 409a valuation and
most startups don't want to do this
until after they've had a fundraising
event so you can issue restricted stock
to employees under this plan and they
will also have vesting and they come
with a whole host of tax and securities
rules which is why the plan needs to be
20 plus pages long but the reason to not
wait too long to do this is because the
longer you wait the more expensive your
stock will get and so you want to grant
yours you want to give your employees
cheap stock or as cheap as you can
because expensive stock is not very
incentivizing I got a cease and desist
letter another company says my company
is infringing on its trademark this is a
problem an early-stage startup it really
doesn't need but we actually see it
happen fairly often founders get very
attached to names and once this happens
it's really tough to let go but your
company is probably too young to have
created much value in the name you
picked and the expense and distraction
of getting into a trademark dispute with
a more established better funded company
can be substantial so your best course
of action is
it go let the name go pick a new name
and get back to work related to this a
few of you emailed the question about
whether or not it's worth it to register
your company's name and get the official
trademark generally we consider a
trademark registration to be something
that can wait it's a nice to have and
not a need to have in the early days of
your startup all right finally I picked
an awesome name for my company but I
have to pay 10k to get the domain this
happens a lot so again don't fall in
love with the name that may cause you to
make bad decisions no matter how great
that name is it is a bad decision to
waste time getting into a lawsuit with a
company that claims you stole its
trademark and it is usually also a bad
decision to spend a ton of money on a
domain so do your research on names like
restric don't just research the PTO
research it and then do whatever is
cheapest and most efficient and move on
okay that's it so now we're gonna have
John and Jason come up and we okay so
what we did is we took you guys emailed
us a bunch of questions and we pulled we
pulled some out we edited them them a
little bit for brevity but we mostly
kept them sort of unfiltered original
style so we're going to go through a
bunch of those now
okay Jason I'm gonna ask you the first
question when you're ready good okay
when does the 30-day IRS clock for
filing an 83-b election start and you
might wanted to start by describing what
an 83-b election form is in case some of
the new here doesn't know yes so to 83-b
election is a tax election so when you
buy stock if you don't make an election
- what happens is you're taxed on the
stock as at best
so each vesting period whichever the
amount of stock that that's whatever the
value of the stock is at that time you
incur an income tax it for that but in
83-b election allows you to be taxed on
the difference between the value of the
stock and the the price that you pay for
the stock on the day that you actually
buy the stock so it's actually by
default in most cases the best thing to
do if when you are start-up founder is
to actually make the election so that
you know because you're gonna be paying
a very nominal price for your founder
stock and so there's going to be no
income taxes because you're going to be
you know if you make the election
because you're gonna be paying the same
amount so you'll pay like a dollar for
your stock and then basically say the
stock is worth a dollar and then you
make the 83-b election and then there
are no more taxes that are going to
accrue on your vesting as a stock grows
and value so if you don't do that which
does happen from time to time you can be
faced with a a very large tax liability
if your company ends up becoming very
very valuable as your stock vests and
the time period from when the 83 below
should be election the 30-day period
that you have to make the filing it
starts from the day that you actually
buy the stock so that is a hard deadline
it includes calendar days it's not a
business day period and if you miss it
there's really not much you can do about
it there are some sort of things that
you can do to mitigate the tax liability
that when if you work with tax lawyers
but if you miss it it's some it can be
pretty bad so that's one thing they
definitely remember okay and I will add
that this is a good reason to pay really
careful attention to the date on your
restricted stock purchase agreement and
the and it should be the same date that
you write the check for the one dollar
paint you just pay attention to that
like you want that all happening on the
same time so you're not really worried
about like oh my gosh what's my actual
start date and the other thing I'll say
about that is 83-b election forms need
to be saved by the company as well so
the individual founder is gonna save
that election form for their own tax
returns and their own files but the
company needs to keep a copy - you put
that in your shared Dropbox you make
sure it's signed you make sure it's
dated and you save it in that safe place
and the company has it you know forever
that's a really important it's one of
the few things that can't be fixed
that's also an important well yeah I
mean Jason was just saying like there
are some there are some fixes sometimes
but they're painful and really expensive
and people look at it in diligence this
is actually one of the few things to
remember yeah if you remember nothing
else from this file you're 83-b election
forms okay so we also got a lot of
questions that touched on a variety of
immigration issues so and here's a
here's a sample question we got I'm in
Canada can you help me get a TN visa so
I can work on my startup in the US Sean
wanted to take a crack at that this is a
difficult you know Jeff said we know
everything but immigrations not
something that were experts on and this
is a situation where you need to speak
to an expert especially if you have
situations where are you going to be you
need to be employed as Caroline was
saying earlier by your company and if
you can't work in the US you can't be
employed because it's illegal and you
better off speaking to an expert now
immigration is particularly tricky you
know it's a political issue obviously
now so it's the landscapes always
changing but it's also it's more of an
art than a science so it's always been
very difficult for us jumping in knowing
the basics to talk about immigration
we're really not experts in this area
and you definitely need to speak to an
expert yeah okay
um Jason should I be a c-corp or an
escort c-corp so if you just file in
Delaware you're trying a c-corp by
default in order to actually be an
escort you have to make an election on a
tax form and the difference between the
two of the C corporis corporate escort
was passed through taxation says tax
transparent so any income earned by the
corporation is then passed through to
its owners the C Corp cuts off the
income with the level of the corporation
and corporation that pays taxes and so
the reason why you want to be a sequel
is that's the kind of entity that
investors are used to investing
and II also when you actually take
investment from outside investors it
will blow the S corp election most of
the time anyway okay John how much
equity should we save for our first
employees our key hires during the
incorporation of the company it depends
on the size of the company and how many
people you need to hire I would say you
know the standards are probably 10 to 20
percent people think is going to be you
know saved for employees but it's
definitely specific to the company so I
would you know this is a situation where
it's very easy for me to say hey you
should be very generous with your
employees and and you know have a
lineman and make sure they're benefiting
from the upside and the company it is
something I believe very strongly and
especially if you have good employees
you want to keep them you want them
aligned with your mission so it's worth
you know thinking about this in a
long-term view having the long-term view
and and you know setting up everyone for
success the online platforms Clerke and
stripe Ellis well I know Clerke for sure
has you can actually create a stop out
option pull at formation if you want to
so if you've already thought that far
ahead and you know you want to have a
plan set up you can do that up formation
I would say though the vast majority of
companies actually wait and don't adopt
a stock option plan so they're a little
further along Jason is it illegal to
have unpaid interns generally yes so you
just went over this in the fundamentals
so you want to avoid unpaid employees
interns are going to be generally
considered employees and then there are
some exceptions you can you can use or
take advantage of for giving people on
you know sort of college credit if
they're college interns or things like
that but you know that's going to take
some work on your part to actually learn
those rules in your project you need to
talk to a lawyer for those things and if
you want to get people the help of
people and you know just pay them in
from in the form of equity again you
know that was already covered by
Carolyn's presentation it could be
contractors but there are standards for
when somebody is classified as a
contractor versus an employee and those
standards got just recently Mort
are harder to to satisfy given some of
the California Supreme Court rulings you
know YC company ones that have fourteen
interns fourteen unpaid interns that was
a big mess okay John there's a ton of
advice out there for how to properly
structure for a non-profit for a
for-profit startup what about nonprofits
what's the best legal practices for
starting a non-profit startup I'm
getting all the questions that I can't
answer it seems fair
the but nonprofits are also completely
different it's a different animal it's
it's different from for profits I mean
the government doesn't favor nonprofits
because the government likes to get
taxes nonprofits are tax free so if you
think about it's going the government's
going to make it difficult to become a
non-profit do you have to go through all
these steps and fill out forms it takes
like nine months I'm not an expert on it
YC is not an expert on it we do we do
donate to nonprofits we accept
nonprofits in our in our program that
said it's always been you have to have a
public your company has to be set up for
the public good there are certain
disclosures you need to make you have to
disclose the top five salaries in the
nonprofit and I'm certainly not an
expert in this area so I don't want to
touch it on on it anymore but it's it's
a completely different animal you're out
there soliciting donations from
foundations rather than raising money
from VCS so it is a totally different
beast Jason can I invite a stranger to
be a partner so that question probably
answered itself generally you want to
work with people that you can trust and
know and so you know before you prey on
somebody as a partner co-founder you you
kind of want to understand how well
you're going to work together whether
you can actually build something
together whether you're going to
actually get along so I think the answer
to that is not if you really want to
make sure that you know you're going to
be successful and even if this the
person asked this question meant partner
like advisor or some other not like a
co-founder but they meant
something else I wouldn't even I would
say don't ever work with a stranger
right and this goes back to what I was
saying about founder breakups I mean
that is that's a recipe for disaster to
work with someone you've only just met
because we've seen brothers break up
like the founder breakup goes through
all levels of relationships so you're
gonna stack the deck against yourself if
you have a stranger involved John what
are key factors to consider while
determining what country should want to
register their parents company in the
quick answer is where where's your
market was your business who were you
you know most people set up in the US
because they're attacking the US market
which is a big market if you're selling
something in India you should be in
India most likely the problem with this
question like the parent-subsidiary
question to me I always think like when
I'm talking to startups keep it simple
like get you know this lecture seems a
little dry and it's a little you know
it's the legal mechanics not the most
exciting thing but it's really pretty
simple if you think about it's like hey
you know form your corporation keep the
be serious keep you documents like don't
have one person in squirrel it away buy
your stock from the company never forget
your 83-b that's the one thing I want to
drill home you know after you buy your
stock evaluate e3b
that's about it like there's not that
much to do as long as you're serious
with parent subsidiaries complexity when
I hear that from from companies early on
I just want to run you're gonna make it
extra hard on yourself with that kind of
stuff
Jason with the explosion of legal
services tech it's possible I may not
need traditional counsel until a
sophisticated angel or institutional
round when do you advise your companies
to stop using these services and migrate
to a traditional law firm
how would you distribute the work
between the two yeah so there there are
a lot of good tools out there right now
so you could use Clerke you can use
stripe out low so you can get pretty far
with them and you know I think when you
get to the point where you're raising
significant amounts of capital you
definitely should get a lawyer
and because a lot of the agreements are
going to be custom and bespoke your
there's going to be some negotiation
when you're just incorporating and
setting up those services we'll take
care of it you could probably go without
counsel you could certainly get counsel
if you want especially going to do
something a little bit more custom when
you get to the point where you're
issuing stock to employees you probably
do want to get you know somebody
involved just because there are some
things that can go wrong if you don't do
it things perfectly and you also don't
want to be careless about having written
promises for stock with various people
so sometimes outside counsel there can
be very helpful making sure you you're
not out over your skis when you're
talking about things like that with
people so John this question is kind of
similar to the one I just asked you so
it's probably the same answer but you
can reiterate from a legal perspective
can i form a start-up and then sell it
while having a full-time job if so what
things should I consider I also think
Jeff touching this earlier but this is
this is kind of asking the impossible
there's no way or I've never seen any
company started part-time on weekends
holidays you know become like a giant
company maybe you know you can do that
on a small scale but this is a you know
we're asking you to start a company out
of thin air and that is very difficult
to grow a giant cut it this is an
all-consuming full-time thing it's not
like oh I'm going to do this as a hobby
so I don't want to sound dismissive but
I just think that's practically
impossible I wouldn't even think that
way like this isn't a part-time gig
Jason our patents ever worth applying
for so this is a this is sort of like oh
that's good you could talk a very long
time about patents and whether it's
useful to or worthwhile applying for
them that the short answer is so pets
are useful for protecting your
technology especially from competitions
and copying your technology your
technology matters if you're pursuing a
software startup you know or tech and
able to enter Internet company
patents tend to matter less there's less
protection under patent law for software
patents anyway and
so your success going to be determined
not by their protectability of your
property under law but rather your
execution under the software if you're
pursuing a life sciences startup they're
duplication is actually easier for
competitors to to you know execute on so
patents tend to be more important and
you know if you have questions about you
know the specific things that you're
doing technology wise and whether it
falls into the weak patent or strong
patent protection bucket
you should definitely consult with a
patent expert or a lawyer on that but
the last part of this is that no company
is you know sort of you know raised
money purely on the strength of their
patent portfolio it's always going to
come down to you know you know or how
good is the founding team you know can
they execute on their vision you know
the Pats are just one part of the puzzle
John I'm thinking about setting up an
advisory board and wonder if advisors
should have equity in my experience
advisory board some more non-us thing
like non Silicon Valley thing maybe in
Silicon Valley we see advisory boards
for the life sciences companies you
would see the you know academics and
professors try to legitimize the the
company as advisors and get a little
stock but this is not something where
you know it's not something we give
stock to people we're with them with
without thought it's more I think the
best quote on advisors somebody said was
like advisors are investors who want
stock for free and that's kind of how I
think about it like you know people
should invest ideally instead of
advising for free shares and I know this
is in like a one-size but some
situations like I was saying it's
appropriate maybe a life sciences
company and you can have consultants who
get stock but it's mostly a situation I
try to avoid Jason what have you seen
founders do when they had to cut off and
fire a co-founder who was a personal
friend
that has anybody here ever had a
roommate who's been a friend it's kind
of like that right so sometimes you know
it's better to not do certain things
with your friend so that you can stay
friends and so if you have started a
company with a friend of yours and it's
not working out and it's oftentimes
because you guys have different ideas
about the direction that company should
go in or somebody's working just a lot
harder than the other person is it's
usually better to just solve that
problem or you know basically you know
resolve that problem as soon as possible
rather than letting it be something that
you think or hope will work out over
time and letting it fester because not
only does it hurt the company it hurts
the friendship too so it's it's
generally better to kind of get to a
quick resolution you know you don't want
to stall on that no that's something I
would add the biggest mistake we see is
people delaying and thinking Oh things
gonna work out and this is a friend
things gonna change it's usually best
that you just end the relationship it's
now working and the startup relationship
the startup reserve reserve different
exactly okay John what is the best
methodology for reviewing potential
loopholes in your privacy policies in
terms of service this is an area where
if you're going to spend money early on
and a lawyer and you have something
that's it's tricky that's a sensitive
startup topic it's worth spending money
on a lawyer but there are excellent
services for privacy policies and Terms
of Service on the internet right now I
you Bend as one and all the major law
firms also have privacy policy
generators but if there's something
specific or I you bend it I'll send out
on the resources tab it's definitely
important it's required if you have if
you're taking somebody's information you
have to have a privacy policy up on your
website or your app in California so
this is something you need to do there
are good services
in certain circumstances you're going to
need to hire a lawyer in this situation
so as many of you probably know if you
are collecting personally identifiable
information from anyone in the EU you're
governed by the GD P R and that's a huge
quagmire and so if you fall into that
bucket even though some of these privacy
policy generators are fantastic they're
not going to get there probably I mean
unless someone's really done a great one
they're probably not going to cover all
the stuff you need to know for GD P R so
you would probably want to get a lawyer
for that let's see Jason should we work
18 hours a day as a co-founder and
founder of our startup how can we
measure and manage our commitment status
for our product so the advice we give
all of our startups is to still exercise
sleep and you know have some semblance
of a life in terms of like maintaining
some of your relationships and
friendships so 18 hours a day is not
something that we would recommend really
except for maybe like short Sprint's
where you need to get something out and
you know just remember that this is just
gonna be a multi-year journey and where
you're building a company so to use the
tired cliches it's a marathon not a
sprint you don't wanna get sick okay
John should we have a shareholder
agreement and what should be included in
a good shareholder agreement shareholder
agreements are really a non-us type of
document it's you it's a document
describes in detail what happens when
when their departures severance bounder
breakups or all different types of
situations and often that can be very
detailed the ones I've seen Canadian
companies have come in with them but
it's really a foreign thing not so much
a US goes back to what we were saying or
what I was saying earlier you want to
keep things simple there's no reason to
have this giant prenup in a situation
for a start-up I mean chances are if
things go wrong with a start-up there's
there are no assets to divide anyway
it's not like a marriage using the
prenup oh no except when you break up
except when you break up in a marriage
there are assets hopefully
a house couch television whatever yeah
you know you need a prenup sometimes of
course startups these detailed documents
that I get from you know the Netherlands
about what happens when a company breaks
up with no assets seemed just like a
waste of time to me overkill to clarify
for some people so this I think that the
person who asked this question was
talking about the shareholder agreements
that John was talking about which is
among founders when you sell preferred
stock to investors in like a series a
financing there are shareholder
agreements and they do govern a lot of
the things that he just talked about but
that's between the company and the
investors so that is different and that
is of course a very u.s. thing so yeah
so just to make sure people weren't
confused about that okay our last
question for Jason many companies have
information about their rounds like
price per share or amount rate raised
displayed on pitch book CrunchBase and
other sites given that this seems to be
due to company charters and filings
being publicly available is there any
way to prevent outsiders from seeing
this detail about your company so that
the the technical answer is yeah there
there are ways there are methods you can
use to actually conceal some of the
information that the charters the
charters the publicly filed document
people can pay you know hundred dollars
or whatever to pull down the Charter
from Delaware and look at some of the
details of your company so that's sort
of like the literal answer but I think
the larger answer is just it's not
something that I would worry about early
because it's it's sort of way down on
the list of priorities in terms of what
you need to sort of think about and plan
for and look there are plenty of
companies that have this information
listed at pitchbook they're doing fine
and plenty of others are you know not
doing fine because and it's not because
they're on pitch Brooker not on pitch
book it's because of other things so
it's just I wouldn't spend a whole lot
of time thinking about this so Jeff and
adora I don't know how we're doing on
time and whether or not you want to do
any there QA
are there any questions shockingly there
are why don't we take just a few
questions okay all right yeah that goes
that I'm not an expert a non-profit
someone thinking oh thank you
she's asking about be corpse which is a
quasi nonprofit and for-profit corporate
social social enterprise where you're
part of your mission is is to help
support the public good that's not
something I'm an expert in unfortunately
many companies have been doing it
recently it's much more prevalent I just
I'm not really qualified just changes
the fiduciary duties right so the whole
goal of the coming the goal of your
average corporation is you make money
for the stockholders right B Corp is
more like there's a social good so the
fiduciary duties on the part of the
management and the directors are
different and like Jon said they're
gaining in popularity so I think we're
gonna see a lot more of them yeah it's
not really ycs things so we don't I
would hesitate to give you any like
advice about them but I know there's
actually a couple good books about them
I have one of them as I've read it but
there's a lot of information out there
about them um you know if not for YC is
maybe but it could be fun yeah it could
be fine it's just we haven't done a lot
of them so we don't really have any data
about what that looks like long-term one
point about a B corporation is is you
can imagine it might not be as
attractive to your typical venture
investor so it depends what the goals
for the company if you're looking to
create a start-up which is high growth
fast growth you won't generally see a B
Corp and most investors probably look at
that somewhat askance I will say we do
have one recently that converted into a
B Corp that had been around for like
five or six years so that's something
you could
[Music]
don't because I don't worry later might
be harder yeah could be done I just
don't know the wisdom of it
president Australian
should I register
[Music]
a new chart you guys know
[Music]
yes it is similar the question is a levy
of a SAS company in Australia and you're
attacking the US market but you're also
in Australia you're not sure where to
incorporate again like the the the key
is like where are your customers it
sounds like you have you're thinking
about the US you know 100% sure and and
I would just figure out like really
where you want to be most you know from
a practical standpoint again like
setting up complex structures is really
what the question that we were talking
about earlier and I have like a little
aversion to that you know it could be a
good situation where it makes sense to
have a parent subsidiary structure for
you but it's a little more complicated
incorporate in the US and then have your
Australian company be a sub but again
you could just incorporate in the US and
just sell into Australia like you could
just not I mean if that's your market
and that's where you want to raise money
just incorporate and be a US company we
always suggest US companies it's much
easier to fundraise in the US and much
more favorable terms in my opinion so I
always tend to push people to be in the
US it's just better for the business
long term
[Music]
these UI co-founders ended here
if you have to restart
there's four in the same question
raise money
okay so his question was when you add
new co-founders like later on maybe a
year or so later do you have to restart
all the original founders vesting
schedule to match the new and the answer
its no you do not so you put you and
your original team of co-founders let's
say you put four year vesting on your
founder stock and then a year later you
find a fourth co-founder you think is
great by the way be a little bit
circumspect about throwing the word
co-founder around like sometimes that
person who comes a year later is just a
key hire and not a founder there's a lot
of emotional attachment to the word
founder and in the Silicon Valley we all
know why but like not everyone's a
co-founder anyway but to answer your
question no you guys will stay on the
same vesting schedule the new person who
came a year later will start four years
on the day that he or she started at
your company now the thing that some of
you probably already know is that when
your investors come in they may decide
they want to restart you all they would
I mean unless you had absolutely zero
leverage so not going to start you back
on square one but sometimes investors
look at your schedule and they say ah
you guys only have about a year left
that's not really enough for us can we
put on another year so that happens
every now and then and again it depends
a lot on leverage but don't be surprised
if that happens did that answer your
question
[Music]
so you talked about having basic culture
we have employers on-site us and totally
Beatles implied public happened in the
u.s. NPD if we don't want to list an
empty in the foreign country so the
question was how do you hire outside the
US when you have a u.s. yeah so the the
short birds unsatisfying answer is going
to be that it depends on which country
because each country has different sort
of rules for who counts as an employee
and who counts as a contractor and what
you have to do in order to actually you
know satisfy those rules and then also
when you actually open up a significant
presence in any sort of foreign country
what you oftentimes have to do is create
a local entity and sometimes that can be
a subsidiary and sometimes it could
actually just be something more simple
like a local branch and again your menu
of options sort of depends on which
country you're going into so I don't
know do you have like a country it
specifically yeah India so India
typically what happens is there's a
subsidiary that's created it's usually
owned 99% by the American parent the
Delaware parent and 1% you know or some
other small percentage but two or one or
two local Indian sort of Representatives
and then that subsidiary is the one that
then hires employees in aviation look at
me
so I think if you want to try and avoid
that kind of structure you know yeah I'm
not an expert on Indian law you probably
need to talk to somebody who actually
has a license in India to actually
advise on the employment issue because
you know it just like the in the United
States various countries have stronger
or weaker protections for when you can
classify somebody as an employer or not
thank you guys very much so sorry to
have to cut off I know there's a lot
more questions live here remember Darby
Wong is from Clerke is having an AMA now
tomorrow but it's open now you can post
questions so if you have questions that
that is an outlet and you can always
work with your group to ask more
questions just one more word on the part
time question which has come up a few
times and we discussed a little bit at
the break the way I look at that it is
certainly true that some companies are
kicked off while people are working in a
full-time job but those aren't really
companies yet they're just projects
they're just ideas once you really start
your company and all of the great
companies have this feature you'll be on
it full-time you'll be on a more than
full time you'll be on at 120 percent so
thank you all for coming in person and
thank you for watching online
[Applause]
just a couple reminders there will be a
conversation with the founder of Y
Combinator Paul Graham on Friday as well
as the AMA tomorrow with Darby next week
we're going to dive into product with
the CEO of YC Michael Seibel and David
recycle from Weebly on building product
and product market fit there are also
several great videos in the startup
library on product that I very much
encourage you guys to take a look at and
lastly
login to the
many of you already have post on the
forum posting your group and figure out
how it works hopefully it'll be good
home for all of you and if you have any
issues send an email to accommodate our
at startup school org and everyone have
a great day thanks
[Applause]
you